madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
membres du gouvernement chers collègues
nous voici donc réunis pour des battes
d'une nouvelle motion de censure suite à
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement sur la 3e partie du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023
je ne vais pas y aller par quatre
chemins jeudi en milieu d'après-midi
j'ai été furieux vraiment furieux
peut-être certains ont-ils entendu ma
colère à cette occasion dans les salons
devant l'hémicycle
l'article 1 c'est à dire le comptable
administratif qui retrace l'année passée
venait d'être au toquée
après 5 heures de discussion générale
par ce rejet nous actions collectivement
la mise en œuvre d'un 49-3 rapide
c'est-à-dire que nous renoncions
d'emblée à discuter des textes et donc à
les corriger et à les enrichir
en bref
nous venions et quand je dis nous je
parle plutôt des oppositions non
seulement d'acter l'inutilité du débat
parlementaire
sur ce texte mais aussi d'abîmer le rôle
de l'Assemblée nationale
à vous madame la Première ministre le
groupe démocrate tient vous adresser
nous remerciements vous avez pris vos
responsabilités en engageant celle du
gouvernement
notre pays nos concitoyens ne peuvent
être pris en otage par des manœuvres
politiciennes de certains
dans ce climat social aussi tendu par
les conséquences du conflit en Ukraine
notamment sur les questions énergétiques
et d'inflation l'action est une
obligation
à vous chers collègues de l'opposition
votre seule ambition pour le mandat qui
vient ne se limite telle qu'à faire des
bons mots au micro voire de la poésie
à dénoncer plutôt qu'à construire
à bloquer les institutions et au final à
provoquer le désordre
je sais bien je sais bien que chaque
formation politique se fixe comme
objectif de remporter les prochaines
présidentielles mais à titre individuel
en tant que député n'avez-vous ni
l'envie ni l'honneur devrait-je dire de
porter ici ou là des combats qui vous
tiennent à cœur
5 ans à être contre tout d'emblée
qu'elle pourrait en être le sens
pour certains ce sera même depuis 10
voire 15 ans qu'ils seront dans cette
opposition totalement stérile
sur un sujet comme le PLFSS il y a
forcément de la place pour faire avancer
des débats qui dépassent largement les
logiques partisanes
mais par votre attitude vous avez
délibérément choisi de laisser le
gouvernement décider entièrement seul
soyons clairs je ne pense pas un instant
qu'il soit possible que vous votiez en
faveur du budget de la sécurité sociale
mais en annonçant d'emblée que vous
auriez contre le texte
en déposant des centaines d'amendements
pour enrayer le fonctionnement de notre
hémicycle
en privilégiant le vote contre plutôt
que l'abstention vigilante
vous renonciez de fait à faire votre
travail parlementaire et vous empêcher
par la même à tous les députés de la
commission des affaires sociales de
continuer le travail accompli
car non déplaise à certains il y a eu un
débat de qualité en commission des
affaires sociales
et ce débat a abouti
j'en profite pour remercier cette
occasion sa présidente et sa rapporteur
général pour la sérénité des débats et
le respect dans les prises de parole
67 amendements dont 26 de l'opposition
soit près de 40 % et ont été adoptés
à titre de comparaison les groupes LR et
socialistes ont fait adopter chacun plus
d'amendements que le groupe démocrate
que j'ai l'honneur de représenter ce
soir
la liste des amendements retenus par le
gouvernement montre que les débats en
commission des affaires sociales ont été
d'une grande utilité
que ce soit sur la clause de sauvegarde
sur le médicament sur la prolongation du
dispositif Tod sur le report du
recouvrement de la jrsaf il y a eu des
avancées
elles auraient pu être consolidées par
un débat de conviction en hémicycle mais
vous l'avez rendu impossible
demain nous aborderons la quatrième
partie du PLFSS celle qui concerne la
prévention
l'accès aux soins le soutien l'autonomie
des personnes âgées la politique
familiale ou encore la fraude
est-ce que nous allons adopter la même
attitude de blocage d'emblée donc de
renoncement une fine
est-ce que nous allons au contraire
saisir pleinement les opportunités que
nous permet la nouvelle configuration de
l'assemblée
personne n'a la majorité absolue vous
l'avez suffisamment répété
de fait seuls des
fêtes seuls des amendements de compromis
peuvent se dégager
ils seront peut-être pas assez pour
certains ou peut-être de trop pour
d'autres
mais ils seront assurément une avancés
pour les Français
je ne vais prendre qu'un exemple les
déserts médicaux
je pense qu'il n'y a personne d'un bout
à l'autre de ces banques qui n'en
conteste le constat
et nous devrions tous reconnaître que
quoi que nous fassions il n'y aura pas
assez de médecins qui sortiront de la
fac dans les toutes prochaines années
alors nous devons agir
car c'est la demande de nos concitoyens
faut-il empêcher certains à s'installer
dans des zones surdotées ou le
conditionner un exercice partiel dans
les territoires en difficulté
faut-il demander des étudiants
de venir passer une partie de leur temps
de formation en zone soudain
faut-il favoriser le développement de la
médecine salariée dans des centres de
soins publics
faut-il
encore
confié davantage d'actes à d'autres
professions de santé pour économiser du
temps médical
à titre personnel je pense qu'il faut
sûrement un peu de tout au vu de l'enjeu
mais ensemble en débattant nous pouvons
trouver les équilibres utiles
comment
on ne préoccupant pas le débat par des
centaines d'amendements
en
s'égoutant et en votant quelques fois
pour carnet des craintes
personne ne va croire que la nuque où
vous voulez l'air ou vous le RN allait
devenir des aficionados de la majorité
mais nous aurons fait oeuvril à la fois
pour les Français et à la fois pour
notre démocratie
dans ce contexte madame la Première
ministre le groupe démocrate modem et
indépendant veut ici vous réaffirmer
avec force sa confiance pleine et
entière dans votre conduite du
gouvernement et dans la mise en oeuvre
du projet de la République
il s'oppose fermement cette motion de
censure et forme donc le vœu que les
débats qui s'ouvriront rapidement sur la
quatrième partie du texte relative au
dépenses permettra une discussion plus
sereine et plus aboutie
l'Assemblée nationale à l'opportunité
d'enrichir le texte quels sont saisis
c'est ce que les Français attendaient je
vous remercie je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]